I'm happy to introduce Janet George at
Western Digital she is building global
core competencies and shaping driving
and implementing big data platforms
products and technologies she previously
served as the managing director chief
scientist and Big Data expert at
accenture where she was responsible for
big data platforms machine learning and
cognitive computer and open innovation
she also served as head of yahoo labs
and research engineering she was
inventing next generation platforms
cloud infrastructure and machine
learning for big data she's also worked
at ebay an apple shields bachelors and
advanced master's degree with a
distinction in computer science and
mathematics with a thesis focus on
artificial intelligence thank you for
joining us thank you very much good
morning everybody my talk today is going
to be about the anatomy of device
physics and the world of device physics
I actually don't come from the device
physics background I kind of grew up in
the advertising world and I grew up with
a search background so that's pretty
much my background but the world of
device physics is very exciting and the
data in that field in that space is huge
learning for me all my experience has
been very practical hands-on on the
field so I'm very applied in my
learnings okay so what I want to cover
today is just give you a background of
what we're thinking about when we talk
about data wide it is so important what
are the issues around data leading to
device physics data specifics about
device physics data what kind of
complexity is associated with that data
what kind of things we try to get out of
that data how do we find the value in
very high large-scale manufacturing data
and then how do we apply machine
learning and deep learning at scale to
this data the kind of data intimacy we
need and then finally leaving you with
how we have embraced complexity and very
large scale leading edge data so this is
a very famous slide everybody knows
about the 3 b's that god has been
talking about for big data for a very
long time
since 2012 and we're very familiar with
volume velocity veracity and so on
variety and so on we still variety still
an issue because trying to figure out
structured unstructured semi-structured
images graph bringing all this together
having all these different data talk to
each other we're still evolving we have
not we've not gotten very good at trying
to figure out how to make all the
different types and kinds of data talk
to each other IBM very shortly started
talking about veracity of data and my
focus is going to be around this
velocity component data which I feel is
the most misunderstood component of big
data or where the complexity really lies
of big data so when you think about
velocities the uncertain component of
data so to give you an example in yahoo
one of my Jobs was really just to figure
out do machine learning on spam on how
attack was happening and this was
usually during registration so when
somebody registered in Yahoo we couldn't
tell whether the register the person
registering was real or was a spam and
we were doing all kinds of machine
learning trying to figure out at the
time of registration how they were
entering their details into the
registration form and whether they were
real or not real and it was very
difficult because as we were training
machine learning to understand the
characteristics of a normal behavior we
were also watching how the attackers
were coming in and building out all
these accounts the data was very
uncertain and we were trying to deal
with attackers and we finally figured
out i think it was 2am one night as I
was sitting with my team and trying to
brainstorm on what are the specific
characteristics of a spammer or an
attacker we found that they were cutting
out the capture images and sending it to
porn sites and having the porn field
solve the capture near real time humans
so there was no no different way for us
to figure out whether humans were
solving the capture or whether you know
some other human farm was solving the
capture and and the key insight was a
time that we captured for a regular
human City
at their desk to solve the capture
versus it being captured and shipped to
a server farm where a real human in some
server farm was actually solving the
capture and shipping that salt capture
back to the site so that's what
uncertain data is all about just to give
you an idea in the world of device
physics we are dealing with this fourth
dimension of data and again i call this
veracity of data I call this uncertain
data uncertainty at scale and when
you're dealing with uncertainty at scale
so the device physics world they create
about 3 to 4 million wafers it's very
very large scale we have a lot of data
and with that data and it's highly
variable data how do we how do we
understand that variability when the
data is constantly changing and how do
we bring out insights from that data so
there's couple of things that the device
physics world do one experimentation
their constant cost per bit is falling
and as you see cause for bit is falling
Apple is creating new and new phones and
and all of the bits that go into this at
very low cost and so is cause for bit
false we have to do experimentation at
scale we have to move from technology
notes so for example if we started with
the 21 nanometer we go very quickly to
70 nanometer or 19 nanometer 70
nanometer and then finally at 15
nanometer when we reach 50 nanometer
there's no more room to compress because
there's only 13 electrons so we can't do
two dimensional NAND we have to start
moving towards three dimensional nand
and three dimensional nand is something
we've never done before so now we're
talking about multi structures multi
layers so we have to do these technology
node experimentations at scale and when
we finish the experimentation with the
different technology nodes we move into
production at scale and if we mess up at
the experimentation stage majority of
production gets messed up or a lot of
cost in production right because we
can't afford to make any errors at scale
in manufacturing we have massive
fabrication units in japan we work with
our partner toshiba and we
reduce these wafers so this data what I
found coming from the advertising world
is really leading edge data we've never
actually figured out how to tackle data
coming out with from Internet of Things
internet of machines at scale at us in
very very variable form extremely
complex so that's some of what I'm going
to talk about i call this
heteroscedasticity six we study about
this high variability high change how to
model heteroscedasticity ada what's what
we can find from this data how do we
deal with all the variances differences
in samples differences in errors
differences in the in what I call the
cooking process as wafers are cooked to
be what they want is to be the final
substrate or the final technology node
so I started to study the complexity of
this data and I found that it's very
interesting when you started to study
the complexity of data I found that this
data the way for data falls in the
complexity factor around quadratic so
it's more leaning towards this upper end
of complexity which I call quadratic
exponential area and so one of my job's
is really trying to figure out how to
tame this complexity and yet do machine
learning at scale so we can find value
and we can find value that would reduce
costs by not in the tens of millions of
dollars but in the hundreds of millions
of dollars that's a very big challenge
because it's very applied it's very
practical all the leaders that I've
talked to in the manufacturing phase of
very risk averse and their risk of us
for a reason because it's high
production high volume and they want to
be able to manage their risk so they
just don't want a model showing them
insights they want a model that can
actually show very very structural
signals that can be actionable so what
are some of the challenges and the
manufacturing data and the technology
node creation first of all materials we
experiment with a lot of different
materials and materials this is the
physics part of it materials have a lot
of issues
they have deformation they don't bond as
material build up then we get into
substrate substrate can overheat there's
actually a heat sink we have to deal
with resistive los deposition issues as
we try to deposit different materials on
top trying to create the silicon we're
very aware of the thickness the
thickness has to be of a certain size
warpage as we try to put all these
things together the way for itself will
warp and the way it warps is very
painful we have vetting layers oxidation
is a big issue for us if the wafer is
waiting outside the equipment for long
periods of time it oxidized off sedation
at scale is lots of dollars wasted and
finally we have diffusion barrier and
the whole whole function of the wafer
depends on d ppm defects per parts per
million and we need to model out and
capture all the known and unknown DP pms
which is a very complex error recovery
mechanism in addition we have coupling
effects so neighboring wafers
neighboring dies will cause behavior
changes in others and adjacent track
interferences these are all the problems
that we have to deal with in the
manufacturing industry and try to get
machine learning in in the middle of
this to try to figure out how to get
value and so then we start building
machine learning models it requires
constant optimization because the data
is highly variable and we're training
and Retraining with change so initially
it's a lot of just going in circles
taking the data training retraining and
so on and so forth and then we can use
very traditional mechanisms like ranking
and waiting for figuring out the
correlations for the DP p.m. and one of
the things I've learned is really
getting intimate with the data and I'll
talk about that I'm a big believer in
allowing the topology of the data to
dictate the machine learning techniques
you're actually going to use on the data
traditionally machine learning people
like to make some assumptions and use
the assumptions on the data linear
regression vs
random forest or naive base or what not
and we found that when we use multiple
modeling methods and we bring all that
together the data tells us which model
actually suits better versus enforcing
11 model on the data and also sometimes
with linear regression we have ability
to fine-tune very nicely as compared to
random forests or other methods so two
metrics we keep track off very closely
in the device physics world one is yield
we live and die by yield yield its
performance and the goal is to get very
high yielding wafers the company's be
our customers for example all the OEMs
apples and Google's and Amazon's of the
world they are very picky about yield
they want to see very high yielding
wafers they want to see top we call them
prime they want to see prime wafers
endurance is counter to eard so if you
have high performance you don't have
high endurance and endurance is about
lifetime value endurance is about data
retention we take the same piece of
wafer and as we are trying to get very
high performance out of the way for
they're also trying to get very high
endurance and the two don't work well
together so usually you'll see the
graphs kind of like this going in the
opposite direction and we've learned
over time to figure out what the balance
looks like between yield and endurance
and we cater to customers that have high
yield needs and customers that have high
endurance needs and as we balance both
of them we try to make sure we don't
lose any single dies in the process
because the way for manufacturing
industry is so cost intensive we try not
to lose anything we actually even use
the scraps and we put it into small
reusable chips and so when we talk about
yield now we're getting into a different
set of problems one great news about the
wafer itself is as you can see
everything on the wafer can be
image can be it's a pattern and we can
look at all these patterns at scale so
this is where deep learning plays a very
crucial role we can train with these
different patterns of failures and
different patterns of success green
versus red we can monitor a tad eye
level there's a there's a lot of
variability so you can I'm also starting
to learn you can't have small sample
sets you have to have very very large
sample sets to see systemic issues of
failures and things like that so
monitoring yield managing yield not just
looking at failures but looking at the
clusters of failures patterns of
failures edge vs. radial vs. Center
short verses side edges vs. coupling
failures there's there's 300 different
clusters of failures and then within
that failures trying to look for what
occurs the most how is the highest
impact can the die still be used not
used so on and so forth so it gets its
layered complexity but the goal really
is to get to 99.9 percent yield and this
is like a dream with our highest running
technology node right now onesie which
is going to be running till 2018 and
we're building the next one that comes
after that which is a three dimensional
NAND we are looking at ninety two
percent accuracy on the yield which is
very high from industry standards only
by leading storage providers have been
able to accomplish that so endurance
when we talk about endurance different
deal right now we're talking about
retention of data we're talking about
lifetime and this is constant cycling of
the day of the chip and trying to figure
out how the data is retained a different
cycles so we start with 10,000 cycles
five thousand cycles two thousand cycles
1,000 cycle and customer comes back and
says can you show us at 5.5 right and so
we can't test for every single cycle
because it's very very expensive to test
so we can do like benchmark tests and
they're not enough because we have to be
able to predict what the way for the dye
will do at different test cycles that is
not actually tested for that I add
requests from customers or OMS that come
back to us so prediction predicting
retention cycles have been wonderful for
us because we've used machine learning
at scale here and we've had a great deal
of Holy Grail type awakening moments
looking at how we were able to predict
the right amount of retention given the
right amount of yield failure
classification I like this a lot and the
reason i like the failure classification
and clustering area is because used to
be we had these prime dies and then i
call it like prime shirts or prime dies
and then we have this intermediate set
of dies that are not so prime somewhat
in the middle and then we have these
loser cases which are basically dies
that just don't function at all they
don't even start so what do you do with
that and we had so we had different
business strains based on these and we
took all that lowend dies and we used to
mix them with other dies and then sell
them and now with the classification we
found a more fine grain tailed failures
for these dyes and so now we are able to
create entire businesses from going from
high-end to mid-range to the third
category so we are able to create a
whole spectrum of new revenue that we
can generate looking at the different
kind and type of failures and the impact
of those failures so we are able to mix
and match different failures the one
that doesn't start at all we can mix
that die with the one that somewhat
starts right and then with another die
that starts but doesn't do anything else
so combining all these different things
we are able to put different pricing
different project at different packaging
on the project and actually sell them so
this is an area of machine learning
that's actually revenue driven brings
back revenue to the company directly
given how much work is being done here
and we are able to do very complex error
recovery which is fascinating getting
into the tail part of the error okay so
this slide I put together just to show
you what I was dealing with when I first
came in here I basically put together
data in different big buckets just for
my own sake to try to simplify it
so manufacturing data we talked a little
bit about that the prep the measure the
clean all that testing and screening and
the Holy Grail is really try finding
nemo right finding all the correlations
values permutation combination can I
actually find a path a structured signal
not a one-off correlations but more or
more what I call a structural
correlation or a correlation but if I
have like 35 response variables and each
variables have 500 dependencies on
correlations what actually matters and
is there a discovery of a new
correlation can I build a machine
learning correlation engine that can
show me every permutation combination of
these correlations that human dome
domain experts have cannot even foresee
of getting there but when we see a new
technology node that's a three
dimensional technology node and we
understand the failure at
experimentation coming from a
correlation that was dynamically
recovered from the field very powerful
so I'm about three minutes i guess and
let me quickly talk about this very
simple example because i want to bring
home the point about data so as i was
doing all this complex stuff HR came to
me and said hey can you just do
something simple for us just predict you
know employee performance this is as
simple as it can be you know it's not a
complex problem can you tackle this
right and I said okay let's try that
that's very simple where's the data what
do we have and what do we need so they
said okay let's get into the analysis so
we quickly got into the analysis
variable importance predictive value we
have our own employees we have our own
managers they're all calibrating our
employees and we have data so we went in
and we looked at all the performance
variables and this example is little
representative because it actually shows
you after we did a lot of work with the
data around demographic job you know
compensation performance none of that
data actually mattered to do predictor
but to predict an employee's performance
what mattered was how they worked in a
team together and what did the
calibration data actually look like and
were they high potential employees and
in high potential program things like
that
and very quickly we waited the
importance of the variables ran a
different kind of models came up with
the results and then I looked at them
and they looked at me and said what's
the key findings and we said well what
the manager calibrated is what the
machine learning model came up with so
they say what did we learn well nothing
because we took the calibration data
that the managers had fed it to these
models and the model spit it out what
the calibration model said so inherently
our data was very biased right and so we
have to start a discussion around how do
we change the game with data what data
should be should we be collecting we
shouldn't take data that's sitting in an
existing company in an existing database
that's been around for a very long time
that's fitted for certain tools and
throw it at machine learning and say can
machine learning show me something
different right can machine learning
beat a domain expert and the answer's no
we have really got to try to collect
unbiased data we have to get away from
bias we have to look at raw data create
annotations the lineage at scale
unfitted for existing tools because when
we do that traditional etl there's a lot
of loss of data and that is one of my
key findings we eat held our way into
every yield tool and we already knew
what the two was going to give us and
then I had to take the same data that
the ill tool was reporting out and say
Janet can you discover something in
machine learning that we don't already
know by the way we have three PhDs and
we are device physics experts and we
have material science physics people
over here and you the machine learning
person tell us something we don't know
so I was on this chase trying to tell
them something they didn't know and I
was getting no way because inherently
the data didn't exist and so we have to
overcome this thing about data loss and
trying to figure out how do we capture
data so now we've gotten to the place
where this data is coming out of the
internet of things we capture the data
from the Internet of Things in its raw
form and so I want to leave you with
this developing an intimacy with data is
really crucial and with the domain
experts asking the right questions
critical thinking observing the signals
and really just looking at systemic
that's how my data looks in the tool and
it's fitted for the tool but if I
actually look closely and I change the
data or I collect different data I can
actually get a completely different
result from the from similar data but
with more around it without the data
loss right so we're looking at data is
so tricky the way we look at the data
and the way we play that the data we can
see many different things about the data
as we ask the right critical questions
and so on so that's pretty much my last
slide key takeaway is the leading edge
of data coming from the Internet of
Things machine data is
heteroscedasticity on this kind of data
is our new challenge and this is where
the leading edge of work remains to be
done thank you